All right, you're done.
Hopefully you started with
the provided buildUriMatcher function.
We begin with the new UriMatcher
that contains the NO_MATCH
function because we don't want
the root node to match anything.
This is typical behavior to make
the code more easy to read.
I'm making a shortcut to
the WeatherContract.CONTENT_AUTHORITY.
Our two base URIs are pretty simple.
Since we've already defined PATH_WEATHER
and PATH_LOCATION in the contract,
we can just assign them to their
corresponding integer constants there.
For PATH_WEATHER, we're going to match
a path with just one additional item.
WEATHER_WITH_LOCATION we're going
to match a path that just has
one additional item on it.
Because location can be a string,
we have to match it with an asterisk.
For WEATHER_WITH_LOCATION_AND_DATE
we're going to match two path items.
The first one of course will
be our location, a string.
But the second one will be our date,
which will always be a number.
Because of that we can
match with the hash sign.